>>Woman: Last time we came here,
we were looking at the shapes,
edges, and the veins of leaves.
>>Narrator: At Vanderburg Elementary
School, students visit this lush,
tropical rainforest
throughout the school day.
>>Woman: What is special
about this leaf that is going
to help it live in the understory?
>>There's just a little bit of
light that will help it survive.
>>Narrator: The rainforest
biosphere is a living learning lab,
a controlled environment full
of tropical plants and animals
that students study
and help care for.
>>Woman: Look at the structure, guys.
Look at this leaf.
Is this the kind of leaf
that we looked at yesterday?
>>Narrator: It's a million-dollar
oasis designed with student input,
built and paid for by
community volunteers.
>>Carolyn: What it took was the
creative minds of many people
and also getting the
community involved.
It was not funded by
our school district.
We were able to get people to
believe in our vision in order
to make this become a reality,
so what we did, in fact,
we created a rainforest
here in the desert
so that children can
compare the rainforest biome
with the desert biome.
>>Woman: What layer of the rainforest
do we call that really high up?
>>The canopy?
>>Lisa: We have been working for a
year now on developing curriculum
for students and teachers
to bring their classes here
and do lessons within our biosphere.
Every grade level has
designated a theme
that runs through the rainforest.
For example, third grade is teaching
about the peoples of the rainforest,
and they come in here
and they can do science
or they can do anything
within the curriculum.
>>Woman: So now, does anybody
know what an artifact might be?
>>Student: An artifact is something
from long ago that
people used to use.
>>Lisa: Within this environment,
they're learning how
everything is connected.
It's not just plants and animals.
It's how people are interacting with
the plants and animals and the types
of effects that we have
on the environment.
>>Narrator: The biosphere has
become a field-trip destination
for other Las Vegas schools, and
that gives Vanderburg fifth-graders a
chance to act as docents
for the visitors.
>>We're going to go to Rainforests
of the World, Central America,
to learn more about Guatemala.
>>This one here is the
open-pit copper mine.
>>Narrator: Another top field-trip
destination is McCaw Elementary
School, where visitors can
explore a replica of a silver mine.
>>Man: Howdy, boys and girls.
Welcome to McCaw School of Mines.
>>Narrator: Tours in the School of
Mines address curriculum standards
in history and earth science.
>>It has all these
levels called steps.
>>Narrator: And in hands-on
activities like panning for gold...
>>Man: Pick up the pan with
the ripples away from you.
>>Narrator: ...McCaw students teach
visitors about the science of mining.
>>Over here are some little drills.
>>Cheyann: It's very interesting
that I get to talk to kids and I get
to teach them what they want to
learn, and they are always looking
at it and talking about it
and saying how cool it is.
>>Man: This is a model of our mine.
You can see a chute going up.
>>Narrator: Community volunteers
built and financed the School
of Mines, and local architect Bill
Snyder volunteered to design it.
>>Snyder: So we went to
Disneyland and we went
to the Indiana Jones ride, where they
created the illusion of taking people
down underground and
into a cave situation.
So we sort of figured
out with the resources
that we had what we could do.
And it's kind of funny,
because the company
that built the Indiana Jones ride
actually did the work here for us
as well, and what we did
to get them to do that,
we had several kids help us
write pleading letters to them,
and we took the model that we built
of this and we set it in their lobby
for about a month before they
said, "Okay, we surrender.
How can we help?"
[Bell rings]
>>Narrator: Local volunteers
also help out as docents.
>>Dorothy: Right now, I
have about 35 volunteers,
and most of them are retired.
Many of them are in their
late 70s or early 80s
and they love interacting
with the kids.
And it's amazing how
they bond with them.
It's a fun thing, and
it keeps us young.
>>Man: Somebody has got to
put it here with the hard hat
and pick up all the loose stuff.
>>James: I like kids, and I try to
make it interesting for the kids.
And anything that will make
it interesting for the kids,
learn for the kids, learn
about Nevada, I'm for it.
>>It looks good.
[ All laugh ]
>>Narrator: The Mine School
and the biosphere are examples
of what can happen when
community members, teachers,
and students come together
to invent new ways to learn.
>>Carolyn: This is unique, and it is
truly thinking outside of the box,
moving beyond the status quo,
and doing something for children
to truly get them excited and turned
on about education
and about learning.
>>Lisa: So what's the part underneath
the canopy of the rainforest?
What's it like?
>>It has some light, but not much.
>>Lisa: That's right.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.